à montréal les gens continuent d'affluer
pour se faire tester le nombre de cas
risque d'augmenter au québec comme
partout au pays
aux urgences le personnel soignant est
sur le qui vive et se prépare à tout le
protocole de protection du personnel
soignant et resserré à montréal depuis
que la contamination et communautaire si
on les protège pas assez tôt et tombent
au combat
le docteur gilbert bouchet travaille aux
urgences à l'institut de cardiologie
pour le personnel soignant le moment le
plus critique ce moment qu'on enlève les
jaquettes
c'est là qu'on devient contaminé c'est
là qu'on peut infecter les autres on le
voit les gens sans facteur de risque
avec les toux de la fièvre on finissait
par faire des tests qui étaient positifs
malheureusement notre personnel soignant
aux urgences fini sa part avoir été
exposées donc avec les modèles sont
annoncés aujourd'hui sa règle la plupart
des problèmes
sa règle la plupart mais pas tous les
problèmes comme la crainte d'une pénurie
d'équipement l'exemple de l'italie fait
peur quand ils ont dit
la pénurie de matériel a été à de
nombreuses reprises un facteur
déterminant dans la lutte contre les
coronavirus les visières on sait c'est
un problème que plusieurs hôpitaux
clamant qu'ils foulent et recyclés
qu'est ce qui se passe avec les stocks
ses potes là car tout ce qui est
question d'équipement relève du
ministère de la santé oms inquiet de ne
pas avoir assez de masques 1,95 pour se
protéger aujourd'hui est ce qu'on a
c'est le masque où les trois prochains
mois
ça s'en remet à ses claques la réponse
est non parce qu'il va avoir des masses
qui vont arriver à ce que des compagnies
qui vont produire du matériel snus est
ce qu'on entend sur le terrain ce n'est
le gouvernement est confiant et se veut
rassurant dans la situation actuelle où
on a un virus ou est-ce que pas de
médicaments n'y a pas de vaccin il faut
absolument que on rehausse ses méthodes
de protection et on est prêt à le faire
la grande inconnue c'est le nombre de
personnes atteintes qui va se présenter
aux urgences
le personnel soignant veut être protégés
pour bien soigner les patients ici à
sept mois de la guerre qui sera du
canada montréal